secretary of defense lloyd austin earned
his reputation during a 41-year career
in the us army
but it wasn't until after his retirement
that he earned the bulk of his seven
million dollar fortune
austin grew up in thomasville georgia
the son of a postal worker and homemaker
his father was a world war ii veteran
and austin planned to serve in the army
for a few years before attending law
school
but after graduating from west point in
austin committed fully to military
service
he became a captain in 1979 and a
lieutenant colonel in 1992
eventually he took over leading roles in
afghanistan and iraq
and became commander of all u.s forces
in 2010
just three years later austin was tapped
to lead the u.s central command
granting him oversight of operations in
both afghanistan and iraq
by the time he left the military in 2016
the commander had earned a lucrative
pension worth an estimated 1.8 million
dollars
then he began his transformation into
something of a professional board member
in august of 2016 austin became a
director of the hospitality management
company
guest services incorporated a month
later
he joined the board of united
technologies corporation
and over the next five years he made 643
thousand dollars in cash
and an estimated 1.1 million dollars in
equity awards
the next year he joined another board
this time for a non-profit called the
carnegie corporation of new york
most outside directors did so for free
but austin collected at least
thirty nine thousand dollars and is
almost four years at the company
just a few months later he added another
position
director at steel manufacturer nukor
he served in that role until the day he
became defense secretary
earning four hundred and eleven thousand
dollars in cash and about five hundred
thousand dollars in stock awards
with all of this new money austin
decided it was time to spend
in 2018 he and his wife purchased a 2.6
million
home in the dc suburbs a month later
he joined the board of tenet healthcare
corporation where he would earn 328
000 in cash and stock awards that
eventually sold for an estimated 1.5
million
dollars he also served on the national
security advisory board
of defense contractor boos allen
hamilton
and the advisory committee of fidelity
investments
together these roles brought him at
least two hundred and forty thousand
dollars
cash slowed when austin became secretary
of defense in january
he sold off his stocks and pocketed more
than two million dollars
while committing to recuse himself for
matters involving raytheon technologies
according to austin he does not intend
to return to defense contractor boards
like raytheon's
quite frankly the defense secretary said
during his confirmation hearing
i'll be too old
you